so what's your take on on rushing to
meet a festival deadline yeah I mean
it's you know people get wrapped up in
the festival deadlines right and
especially ones like Sundance and
Tribeca but not and we fell in that that
same kind of trap and we had finished
filming and then had literally two
months to finish a cut for Sundance
because we thought you know Sundance is
the end-all be-all and let's just do it
let's do two months of sprays e marathon
editing may hire film and even the
entire film we had nothing like a blank
timeline let's finish a film in two
months just completely completely insane
I wouldn't recommend it to ever yeah
yeah so it was completely just based on
that that deadline and it was like we
weren't really taking the film's best
for stick behind it was just more about
like getting that deadline and you know
we thought that it would be good because
it will give us deadlines a deadline
throw is good for artists involve a blob
but it's just like you have to be really
careful about that because now we found
that we've had to go back and do a lot
of work and pack a lot of stuff that we
would have been able to just go through
if we want to impose those unrealistic
deadlines in the first place so the film
has suffered a bit because we pushed so
hard for that first one and made our
film around someone else's deadlines
yeah and ultimately it's good to have a
festival strategy and that's hugely
important and we're certainly going to
do the festival's when the film is done
but developing a strategy for festivals
is very time-consuming and when you're
trying to make a movie and edit a film
which is not there's no way to put the
two worlds together I mean if you're
when you're editing the film make the
best film that you possibly can and
that's that's ultimately in the end
where and how you're going to find
success if you have a great film right
so yeah we made the mistake of trying to
do both at the same time it's just it
did not a good idea how many hours of
footage we're working with when you you
have this blank timeline man it's hard
these days of it because you know
nothing's digital and back in the days
when Toews tape you just count the
number of tapes right because roughly
that was an hour each tape but terabytes
and terabytes here I think we're at six
terabytes or something like that which
is a huge amount and you have to back up
that footage right and so do some gobs
and gobs of hard drives at the office
right now it's fennel yeah and the
majority of the footage is also in
Haitian Creole or probably what half
half minute so getting it translated and
and having to be up against those
deadlines as well like it just it just
kind of became this nightmare it's
probably a couple hundred hours of
footage I'm guessing yeah it's got to be
at least under yeah what do you do to
recharge when you feel like you're too
close like sometimes the film courage
calm I'm just too close to it and have
to step away i'm answering emails all
day i'm putting up articles so what do
you do to kind of say you know what okay
I have to just walk away because I'm
starting to get too close to it and too
frustrated and because things aren't
working yeah is there a secret to that
is rose n yeah I've been shaken luckily
it's been happening for so long that we
can you know slot other projects in and
other creative outlets in to where we
can kind of put our full selves into
that stuff and actually rest from the
source we've had to do that more than
once yeah two or three times just go and
make a short film or do another daughter
if you know stuff like that and that I
think that that's kind of the best way
because every time you do a project you
learn something and then I'll come back
and take take that put that energy back
into the store
good to recharge yeah one of the
challenges of making documentaries or
films in general is that you start off
with a really exciting idea and you're
really pumped about it but you don't see
the payoff for 23 years you know with my
first film was four years basically and
so I think it's important to have like
little successes and victories along the
way where you're taking breaks from the
larger project that you have going on
and you're feeding yourself with these
smaller projects creatively and just
feeling good about what you're doing and
will append about yourself you know
because it can get pretty depressing
after you know a few years you've been
with the same project and you haven't
seen anything come of it it's it's
struggle yeah right and you see other
people that are like on pedestals and
then you go what am i doing wrong so
yeah but you don't hear about those
other people on pedestals until we're on
the pedestal you know it's like you
don't hear about the four years that
they've been working to get there and so
yeah it's it's definitely hard
bye